hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
betrayals backstabbings and
double-crosses are a dime a dozen in
videogames some are so obvious we
prepare ourselves hours in advance some
deceptions built quietly in the
background and some well some come out
of nowhere and punch you straight in the
gut here are six times we were stabbed
in the back by someone we thought we
could trust at this point in the video I
usually say watch out for spoilers for
the following games but by putting them
up then you'll already know about the
twist so the best thing to do is to stop
watching now consider yourself warned at
first general Shepherd from call of duty
modern warfare 2 comes across as the
perfect military leader in a world
filled with espionage and low-quality
airline border controls too soon sorry
sorry my bud
Shepherd even watches over your training
exercises and the tell-tale sign he's a
trustworthy chap we are unable to shoot
him Shepherd
sends soap and the gang on numerous
missions and in no time at all we've all
but prevented the next world war and the
single task remains to download the
enemy's operation playbook sounds easy
enough doesn't it off goes Roach and
everyone's favorite SAS badass ghost
who's really called Simon but that
doesn't sound as cool so we'll stick to
ghost the mission is damn hectic but we
get the objective done and our fearless
leader is on hand to help us into the
escape chopper
that's what a loser
[Music]
absolutely gut-wrenchingly we see ghosts
kicked into the dirt and set alight just
as we get the radio confirmation that
Shepard is not to be trusted
[Music]
[Music]
thanks a lot captain price if you said
that 10 minutes earlier things would be
very different now just in case you need
closure on this one
Shepard ultimately wants a war between
the US and Russia but it doesn't go too
well for him when he starts a bar fight
with none other than Captain Price and
soap MacTavish
I'll have to number nine number nine
large number six but extra tip number
seven two number forty-fives one wit
cheese and a large so
Grand Theft Auto is rife with betrayal
Big Smoke in San Andreas Demetri or
Michelle in GTA 4 even the very first
scene in Grand Theft Auto 3 sees our
overly trusted ass double-crossed Lance
Vance on the other hand would we never
even think about stabbing us in the back
his white suit and purple shirt
combination require daily washing and
pressing so Lance doesn't have the time
to double-cross us or in this case Tommy
Vercetti Lance and Tommy develop a
bromance throughout GTA Vice City
avenging the death of lances brother
now you can feed me all this lonely
tough-guy crap but I know one day I'm
gonna save your ass and you're probably
gonna want to kiss me Wakko slowly as
that bromance becomes a criminal empire
the to start to fall out leading to
Lance setting up Tommy by revealing he
was using counterfeit money to pay off
another mob boss but at least someone
and you're chicken [ __ ] organization
knows how to do business
isn't that right Lance sorry Tommy this
is vice city this is business
you sold us out no I saw you out I saw
you out the real cash she's upstairs in
the safe luckily for us Tommy Vercetti
isn't one to be double-crossed and hands
out retribution to his one-time BFF by
the end of the fight Tommy even replaces
his former friend with another
untrustworthy specimen now Ken I think
this could be the beginning of a
beautiful business relationship after
all your conniving backstabbing two-bit
thief and I'm a convicted psychotic
killer and drug dealer I'm pretty sure
things will go much better this time for
our Tommy did I ever tell you the
definition of insanity
Far Cry 3 will be forever remembered for
vas and his definition of insanity
although his sister dealt the biggest
betrayal here on the rock Islands once
music guru will.i.am takes us to visit
Citra there's an instant bond between us
the character we play as Jason wants the
mythical powers Citra controls to save
his friend from captors a mix of
hardcore hallucinogenics and rhythmical
writhing around cause Jason to fall head
over heels for Citra I have no idea what
they're doing here by the way by the end
of Far Cry 3 Jason is a warrior a dab
hand at murdering and has some sick ink
to show off - in our last act we must
decide whether we should save our
friends or go the whole hog and off our
friends and settle down with Xetra and
probably have three four kids and maybe
a new loft conversion easy choice we've
done it now sit back and enjoy a little
more dry humping
well I didn't see that coming did you at
least she didn't stab us in the back I
suppose Jason you should have stuck to
grinder or tinder rookie mistake
the ultimate of your time and our child
will lead the rocky probably the
greatest betrayal or piece of
manipulation happens in Bioshock and
he's all about the phrase would you
kindly terrible terrible accent I'm so
sorry would you kindly get this
I'd be head to Ryan's office and killed
a son-of-a-bitch
our character Jack wakes up with a bout
of amnesia as a side thoria how many
games actually use amnesia as a plot
mechanic I used to know the answer to
that but I can't remember for the moment
for some reason jack is aided through
the underwater city of Rapture by atlas
a humble man who is trying to escape
with his family
Jack and Atlas work together to find
raptures creator Andrew Ryan and then we
realize we are butter pawn and have been
manipulated by our so-called friend
atlas Ryan attempts to free our mind but
um that doesn't go too well for him and
his skull is caved in with a golf club
ah juices
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
honestly when the would you kindly
phrase was revealed as a cold word it
absolutely blew my mind
truly one of the greatest story twists
in videogame history and just in case it
still works would you kindly send me all
the money in your bank account please
any takers
no my worth a try
Corvo attano is not a man to be messed
with just ask anyone he meets in
Dishonored
after being framed for the murder of
Jessamine the ruler of these lands Corvo
wait six months to finally escape prison
and links up with a resistance group and
begins murdering everyone linked to that
assassination
[Music]
once he's got through them all the
resistance go to their local pub for a
celebratory drink like one big happy
dysfunctional family our job is done
fade to black
a ho no that's not how it goes down time
for the betrayal corvo's drink is
poisoned and it appears he has died
luckily the man in charge of poison
samuel quite likes Corvo and lets us
live why I keep sticking my neck out for
you elude me but I only gave you half
the portion Corvo
the remainder of the game sees Corvo
hunt down and murder all our former
brothers and sisters-in-arms reinstating
his illegitimate daughter as the ruler
of the empire
but let's not open that can of worms
just yet let's also take a second to
recognize Dishonored as the game which
began the Manneken challenge do you
remember that rubbish yeah I did it too
I suppose it was better than the Harlem
shake anyway no one's playing games with
you Mr Marston but if we were to play
some games there'd be some interesting
ones we could play sure like hanging you
for murder or confiscating all your
property like that little farm of yours
or or having you put in electric chair
those are the sort of games we could
play all the way through Red Dead
Redemption
it seems pretty likely Edgar Ross will
double-cross our hero John I mean John
is a wanted bank robber with more
confirmed kills than heart disease and
dead gross well he's an FBI agent when
John decided to go straight and undo all
his wrongdoing Edgar Ross makes him a
deal he cannot refuse it's simple
take down his former gang and live out
his days on his own ranch all the way
through Red Dead Redemption we are
taught not to trust Ross and always look
over our shoulder as he's likely to
change his mind but he doesn't see you
around John better stay out of trouble
come on Archer let's go find somebody
else we can annoy once John completes
his side of the bargain he goes back
home to his family and lives happily
ever after hey we had no reason to doubt
Ross he kept his word
maybe the law and order in these lands
can be trusted after all of course this
isn't the end and betrayal is fast
approaching when Edgar Ross and his
Merry Men come to visit John
John run escape and survive he'll know
his newfound honor won't allow it as he
meets the double-cross head-on other
time I remember thinking it's just a
scratch he'll be okay after a few days
in bed but suddenly I was wrong
to relieve that sour taste in our mouths
Red Dead Redemption gives us one parting
gift
Jack Marston John's whiny little son is
now a fully grown man out for vengeance
against Edgar Ross now that ending is
much more satisfying
so there you have it there's six
betrayals we didn't see coming
did I miss any from the list please let
me know your thoughts a quick shout out
to those people from our discard who
suggested games for this video
kaksi pablo Jaramillo Aled Griffis and
brock jones you guys are awesome thank
you very much for your help if you'd
like to contribute to one of these list
videos and please check out our discard
I'll put the link below I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]